you've got joe biden he is the most
prominent democrat in the country
president of the united states here is
the kind of soaring periclean rhetoric
that we're getting from president joe
biden
i'm also sending to congress a
comprehensive package
of that will enhance our underlying
effort to accommodate the russian
oligarchs and make sure we take their
take their their ill-begotten gains
we're going to accommodate them
we're going to seize their yachts their
luxury homes and other ill-begotten
gains
of putin's kleptocracy
yeah
kleptocracy and clip the guys who are
the kleptocracies
but these are bad guys
now you know what the democrats do
when joe biden just stumbles over his
own words has no idea what he's saying
can't pronounce certain words
uses words in a way that don't make any
sense whatsoever repeats himself within
the very same breath when they when he
does all of that when he shows obvious
signs of cognitive decline
the libs say oh well you know that's his
childhood stutter
that's what they say they they trotted
this line out during the 2020
election and specifically the democrat
national convention in 2020 they had to
explain joe biden's obvious senility and
so they said well it's because of this
childhood stutter
and the libs just went with that they
said yes it's the childhood stutter i
actually i had liberal friends and
relatives tell me they said no michael
you know what we hear is that's just the
way joe biden always was
what are you talking about biden's been
in politics for 50 years you know what
he always was did you forget so soon
this is obviously a market change they
say no no just a childhood stutter what
a childhood stutter that disappeared for
70 years and then just came back in the
man's late 70s
roaring with a vengeance no of course
not that's insane
cannot be overstated
how dramatic the cognitive decline of
joe biden has been in recent years just
to compare it i'm just picking a clip at
random there's a clip that was going
around the internet this is joe biden 20
years ago yelling at a u.s marine while
he was senator from delaware the context
actually doesn't really matter listen to
this man and tell me that the only thing
that's wrong with joe biden today is a
cognate is a is a childhood stutter
i respectfully suggest they have
responsibilities slightly above your pay
grade
slightly above your pay grade
to decide whether or not to take the
nation to war alone
or to take the nation the war part way
or to take the nation to war half a
halfway
that's a real tough decision that's why
they get paid the big bucks that's why
they get the limos and you don't
i mean this sincerely i'm not trying to
be flip
because i think and that's why i was set
at the outset the reason why i'm glad
you did what you did
we should come to our milk
we should make a decision
but in terms of whether the secretary of
state
has
no more to consider than you do as the
arms inspector
you didn't get in didn't get my job done
get me in
period you made the deal right that's
the deal a deal's a deal get me in scott
ritter i'm ready to go that's not how it
works
so joe biden
is the same nasty man that he's been his
whole career we kind of forget that
because he's he's created this image
really the the establishment media have
created this image of nice old happy
uncle joe licking an ice cream cone he's
not a nice guy he's a very very nasty
man who's done very nasty things
throughout his career and he always uses
weird phrases that's nothing new either
got to come to our milk okay we got it
and so
those sort of weird colloquialisms folky
sayings that has been part of joe's
career too
but that's not what we're seeing when
joe biden says the then the russian
yachts and the kleppy cla cleptum
who's winona ryder and the uh
anyway bad guys huh when he does that
it's it's not a stutter that's happening
okay it's not just some lifelong speech
affliction that he's had it's because
he's in clear clear cognitive decline
he's got one one thousandth the energy
today that he had 20 years ago forget 20
years ago five years ago six years ago
during the biden administration or
during the obama administration rather
when he was the vice president
biden had much more
energy and acuity he's never been the
brightest bulb in the pack but he at
least had a kind of political sharpness
that's gone that's totally gone and he
seems
vacant he seems very much
in trouble did you like that clip i'm
glad you did you got to ring the bell
and subscribe that way you'll get
notifications for all the clips and all
the special interviews and all the
special breakouts and all the episodes
and the whole
michael knowles show
universe
you got to subscribe also go to apple
podcast spotify stitcher wherever you
get your audio podcast type in the
michael knowles show if you would be so
kind leave a five-star review we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you